[Musik]
die herausforderung ist sicher glücklich
die mentaler sehr extreme mir seinen
alle klimazonen eingesetzt zum beispiel
bei geiselbefreiungen aber bei
rückholung von österreich dann aus dem
ausland sowie je zwei verona
[Musik]
das arbeit muss sich permanent den sehr
hohen intensität das macht glaube den
großen unterschied zu anderen drucken
körper nicht nur beim bundesheer sondern
vielleicht weltweit aus
[Applaus]
[Musik]
erst mal wirklich der unglaublichste tag
bei der mit kakteen ich für euch
verbracht habe und was ich mental drauf
hab zwar körperlich darauf wie das team
zusammen funktioniert das war so
beeindruckend danke nochmal für einen
wahnsinns tag für euch der tag war mit
glas geht und wenn es am tag gegeben hat
in meinem leben wo ich mich sicher
gefühlt aber so richtig sicher wenn wir
das bei euch dass ich gut